mes chers concitoyens
près de trois semaines après l'entrée en
vigueur des mesures de lutte contre
l'épidémie a lancé le 31 mars dernier
par le président de la république je
viens ce soir avec plusieurs membres du
gouvernement vous dire où nous en sommes
et vous présenter les perspectives qui
se dessinent pour les prochaines
semaines la situation sanitaire
s'améliore dans notre pays nous
constatons depuis dix jours une baisse
réelle de la circulation virale le
nombre quotidien de nouveaux malades a
baissé de 17% en une semaine et
s'établit aujourd'hui à un peu plus de
30 mille cas par jour
cette décrue concerne près de 80% des
départements elle est plus marquée dans
les territoires ile-de-france au de
france alpes-maritimes où l'épidémie
étaient reparties à la hausse plus vite
et dans lesquels nous avions pris des
mesures anticipées dès le 20 mars
dernier
le pic de la troisième vague semble donc
derrière nous et la baisse de la
pression épidémique est engagée pour
autant nous devons rester très vigilants
nous avons bien la confirmation que nous
faisons face à une souche le variant dit
britannique qui est plus contagieuse et
donc plus difficiles à combattre ce qui
explique la baisse que nous enregistrons
est moins rapide deux fois moins rapide
que lors du confinement du mois de
novembre
le niveau de circulation virale se
réduit mais il reste élevé dans une très
large partie du pays
quinze départements ont un taux
d'incidence encore supérieur à 400 pour
cent mille habitants et 30 autres
départements se situe entre 300 et 400
nous devons donc rester lucide sur la
situation est pleinement mobilisé pour
poursuivre nos efforts on voit bien du
reste que l'épidémie reste active
partout chez plusieurs de nos voisins
européens en particulier je pense
notamment aux pays bas ou en allemagne
où l'épidémie progresse à nouveau
légèrement depuis deux semaines
et ce en dépit de mesures de freinage
strictes qui s'applique dans ce pays
depuis plus de quatre mois déjà dans nos
établissements de santé la pression
reste très forte puisque nous comptons
actuellement près de 7600 personnes
hospitalisées en soins critiques dont
c'est à dire près de 80% sont touchés
par l'aco vide nous faisons face à cette
situation exceptionnelle en ayant réussi
à doubler le nombre de lits par rapport
à nos capacités normales cela représente
une charge très lourde et durable pour
l'ensemble des personnels soignants et
impose je tiens à le souligner des
efforts exceptionnels avec la
mobilisation de nombreux renforts des
déprogrammations des transferts de
malades entre régions et des équipes
soignantes dont nous devons mesurer le
niveau de tension de fatigue
d'inquiétude mais aussi de dévouement et
d'engagement exceptionnelle auprès des
malades
je me rends régulièrement auprès de ses
équipes avec le ministre de la santé et
je veux leur dire une fois encore notre
reconnaissance et celle de toute la
nation
les derniers chiffres semblent toutefois
indiqué là aussi des signes positifs à
l'échelle nationale le nombre de
patients admis en réanimation a atteint
un plateau
depuis quelques jours les dernières
simulations réalisées par l'institut
pasteur laisse penser que nous avons
atteint le haut de la vague de hausse
des hospitalisations et d'oise espérer
le début d'un reflux d'ici quelques
jours
mais vous le savez nous devons rester
d'autant plus vigilant et que l'épidémie
reprend fortement dans certaines parties
du monde et il est de notre devoir de
nous en prémunir en maintenant un haut
niveau de contrôle sur les déplacements
notamment vers ou en provenance de pays
confronté à une situation sanitaire à
haut risque
depuis un an maintenant je vous rappelle
qu'on ne peut rentrer en france en
provenance d'un pays extérieurs à
l'espace européen que dans des
conditions très strictes
seuls peuvent venir les ressortissants
français et européens
les personnes résidant sur notre sol
ainsi que certaines catégories limité de
personnes justifiant d'un motif
impérieux
tous doivent justifier depuis la fin
janvier de la réalisation d'un test pcr
négatif et observer une période d'auto
isolement de sept jours l'apparition de
nouveaux variants plus résistants
vaccins notamment au brésil et récemment
en inde justifie de durcir encore nos
conditions pour les arrivées en
provenance des pays les plus à risque à
ce jour ces variantes circulent peu sur
notre territoire
puisqu'ils ne représentent que 4% des
cas positifs et cette proportion a
d'ailleurs tendance à se réduire depuis
quelques semaines il faut donc tout
faire pour que cela ne s'inverse pas à
partir de samedi un système de contrôle
renforcé sera donc mis en place pour les
personnes arrivant du président
d'argentine dû chili d'afrique du sud et
d'inde
la liste des motifs autorisant une
arrivée en france sera encore restreinte
la réalisation d'un test sera
systématisé non seulement au départ mais
aussi à l'arrivée
et surtout chaque personne fera ensuite
l'objet d'une quarantaine stricte décidé
par action était préfectoral est assorti
de contrôle par les forces de l'ordre
le ministre de l'intérieur vous
précisera les modalités de ces contrôles
renforcés aux frontières
nous accentuons également les mesures de
protection de nos territoires
d'outre-mer qui font face à des vagues
successives
sans lien avec ce qui se passe en
métropole c'est le cas aujourd'hui en
guyane en martinique et à la guadeloupe
où nous venons de renforcer nos mesures
et où nous allons intensifier le
programme de vaccination comme à mayotte
et à la réunion qui sont exposés aux
variants sud africain mesdames et
messieurs l'amélioration relative mais
réel de la situation sanitaire et les
mesures renforcé de protections aux
frontières
nous permettent aujourd'hui de confirmer
la reprise des enseignements scolaires
la semaine prochaine comme l'avait
annoncé le président de la république
dès ce lundi 26 avril
tous les élèves des écoles maternelles
élémentaires ainsi que leurs enseignants
regagneront leurs classes fidèle en cela
à notre objectif depuis la fin du
premier confinement d'assurer aux élèves
la continuité de ce lien physique le
plus qu'il soit possible
j'entends parfaitement les arguments
suivants lesquelles l'amélioration de la
situation sanitaire ne serait pas encore
suffisante pour permettre la réouverture
des écoles mais nous avons la conviction
que les dégâts causés par la fermeture
prolongée des écoles sont tout
simplement catastrophiques et peuvent
entraîner des dommages de long terme en
termes éducatifs mais aussi
psychologiques qui doivent nous
préoccuper tout autant que ceux
directement liés à la pandémie
donc oui nous assumons une fois encore
ce choix mais nous devons en tirer aussi
toutes les conséquences en
l'accompagnant de conditions strictes
permettant la reprise des cours lundi
prochain dans un cadre sanitaire le plus
protecteur possible le ministre de
l'éducation nationale les détaillera
dans un instant ce cadre vous le verrez
prévoit à la fois un protocole strict et
un renforcement massif des capacités de
test à tous les niveaux élémentaires
collèges et lycées aussi bien pour les
élèves que pour tous les personnels se
seront dès la semaine prochaine plus de
tests salivaires pour les écoles
élémentaires
nous en réalisons 250000 par semaine fin
mars nous en proposerons 400000 par
semaine à la reprise avec la perspective
d'atteindre 600 mille tests d'ici la mi
mai nous concentrerons ce dispositif de
dépistage dans les départements où
l'incidence est la plus élevée en
complément des tests salivaires
la grande nouveauté de la reprise
olivier
on y reviendra sera le déploiement des
autotests il s'agit d'un prélèvement
nasal
mais beaucoup plus simple et léger que
pour les tests pcr et dont le résultat
est connu en 15 minutes
nous avons passé des premières commandes
massives 64 millions d'autos test qui
arriveront à partir de la semaine
prochaine ils seront proposés à tous les
personnels de l'éducation nationale dès
la semaine prochaine puis à tous les
lycéens à partir de la semaine du 10 mai
pourquoi seulement aux lycéens cette
limite
tiens au fait qu'à ce jour s'est auto
test sont réservés aux plus de 15 ans
la haute autorité de santé se prononcera
en début de semaine prochaine sur la
possibilité de les proposer à des élèves
plus jeunes et en fonction de sa
décision nous nous tiendrons prêts à les
déployer plus largement dans des
conditions forcément encadré que nous
devrons adapter en fonction des âges des
élèves
je vous rappelle aussi que depuis le
week-end dernier
la vaccination des personnels
enseignants et de la communauté
éducative âgés de plus de 55 ans a été
facilitée avec un système d'accès
prioritaires et de places réservées dans
nos centres de vaccination ce dispositif
est du reste ouvert à d'autres
professions dites prioritaires qu'il
s'agisse des policiers et gendarmes
les personnels de la petite enfance ont
encore de nombreuses professions
exposées comme les conducteurs de bus
des agents de propreté ou encore les
salariés des grandes surfaces
commerciales
la liste de toutes ces professions a été
établi à l'issue d'une concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé y reviendra
dans un instant et six nouveaux pouvons
procéder à cet élargissement
c'est que notre campagne de vaccination
progresse et qu'elle progresse bien
d'ici la fin de la semaine 14 millions
de personnes auront reçu une première
dose de vaccin ce qui représente un
quart de la population adulte
nous affichons aujourd'hui un rythme de
vaccination parmi les plus rapides
d'europe qui nous permet de vacciner
environ deux millions et demi de
personnes chaque semaine c'est le
résultat d'une organisation et d'une
logistique exemplaires il est
aujourd'hui possible de vous faire
vacciner par votre mère
de nos concitoyens âgés de plus de 75
ans 70 % des professionnels de santé ont
aujourd'hui reçu une première dose
cette stratégie progressive vise je vous
le rappelle à protéger les plus fragiles
et les plus à même de développer des
formes graves de la maladie
notre objectif final reste le même avoir
pu proposer la vaccination à tous d'ici
la fin de l'été grâce à cette
mobilisation exceptionnelle
nous sommes sur le bon chemin pour
atteindre notre objectif de 20 millions
de personnes ayant reçu une première
injection
à la mi mai et 30 millions à la mi juin
cela suppose d'abord évidemment de
recevoir toutes les doses que nous avons
commandé il a pu arriver
vous le savez que nous subissions des
retards au cours des derniers mois c'est
plutôt inverse depuis quelques semaines
puisque les dernières négociations
conduites par la commission européenne
nous ferons bénéficier de plus de 7
millions de doses supplémentaires que
pfizer nous livrera entre début mai et
fin juin
cela suppose aussi au delà du sujet des
livraisons que nous utilisions tous les
vaccins dont nous disposons beaucoup de
vaccins ont été développés sont utilisés
dans les différents pays du monde
seul un petit nombre ont été autorisés
en france et en europe sur la base d'une
évaluation et d'un suivi rigoureux qui
nous permettent d'en garantir
l'efficacité et la sécurité
c'est le cas du vaccin astrazeneca dont
l' agence européenne du médicament et la
haute autorité de santé françaises ont
encore réaffirmé récemment qu'il est
aussi efficace contre les formes sévères
que le finder ou le modern à certaines
formes rarissime d'effets indésirables
olivier ferrand il reviendra ont été
constatés les autorités médicales
alan tirer des conséquences en
recommandant de ne l'utiliser delà de 55
ans
ce que nous appliquons évidemment je
vous rappelle que nous comptons encore
11 millions de personnes de plus de 55
ans qui n'ont pas encore été vaccinés
j'ai 55 ans et je me suis vacciné avec
l'astra zeneca comme 200 millions de
personnes dans le monde
j'invite chacune et chacun de ceux qui
le peuvent en faire de même car de notre
capacité à étendre rapidement notre
couverture vaccinale dépendra évidemment
aussi notre capacité à avancer dans la
voie d'un retour progressif à une vie
normale
nous aspirons tous nous l'attendons tous
et je pense évidemment au premier chef à
toutes les femmes et les hommes qui sont
aujourd'hui empêchés de travailler
certains depuis maintenant près de six
mois
cette réouverture comme le présent de la
république l'a indiqué de 31 mars
dernier nous voulons nous souhaitons
qu'elle puisse commencer autour de la mi
mai mais compte tenu du contexte
sanitaire encore fragile que nous
connaissons nous devrons l'organiser de
telle sorte qu'elle se fasse par étapes
de manière forcément prudente et
progressive
si nous voulons pouvoir permettre la
réouverture du plus grand nombre
possible de lieux et d'activités cela ne
pourra pas être le cas pour tous
notamment pour ceux qui en train des
concentrations importantes de public
sans possibilité de respecter les gestes
barrières et ce qui pourra rouvrir dès
la première étape ne pourra se faire que
dans des conditions strictes qui
s'assouplirait avec le temps d'ici le
début de l'été en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
le cas échéant sur une base
territorialisées nous y avons travaillé
avec l'ensemble des secteurs
professionnels concernés et ce travail
de concertation va se poursuivre dans
les prochains jours après les crèches
les écoles maternelles et élémentaires
qui rouvriront donc la semaine prochaine
les collèges
et les lycées reprendront en distance
yale puis normalement à partir du 3 mai
en présentiel dans des conditions de
georges que jean michel blanquer
précisera à partir du 3 mai également
nous pourrons lever les contraintes de
déplacement journée est envisagée sous
réserve de l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire
un nouveau train de l'ouverture autour
de la mi mai qui pourrait commencer par
les commerces certaines activités
culturelles et sportives et les
terrasses cette liste n'est pas
définitivement fixée
elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes
nous aurons l'occasion de donner les
orientations et précisions nécessaires
dans les tout prochains jours
je demande maintenant à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
olivier ferrand de bien vouloir venir
vous parler de vaccination et de
dépistage monsieur le ministre monsieur
le premier ministre votre système de
dépistage vous le connaissez bien
maintenant il permet de réaliser entre 2
millions et demi et 4 millions de tests
par semaine tous gratuits je le rappelle
dans douze mille point de tests avec
toujours invendu des résultats dans 90 %
des cas dans les 24 heures qui suivent
notre stratégie je le rappelle elle
repose sur deux piliers en matière de
diagnostic d'abord ce qu'on appelle le
diagnostic en tant que tel c'est le
diagnostic individuel c'est la démarche
individuelle auprès des patientes pour
voir s'ils sont porteurs ou non du coc
vide
ce diagnostic repose sur les tests pcr
ainsi que sur les tests antigénique qui
permet donc de dire si vous êtes malade
ou non et nous avons également la
stratégie de dépistage qui est différent
du diagnostic c'est qu'on va aller entre
guillemets à la pêche c'est à dire qu'on
va aller chercher dans la population
générale y compris chez des gens qui
n'ont pas forcément de cas contacts dans
leur entourage
s'ils sont positifs ou non aux qu'ovide
pour cela nous avons une stratégie que
vous connaissez qui est celle des tests
salivaires qui sont réalisés dans les
écoles et nous avons désormais
conformément à l'avis du conseil
scientifique
les autotests qui viennent compléter
cette stratégie de dépistage
c'est un outil qui va être utile qui
complète notre arsenal existants mais
qui ne va pas remplacer les tests pcr ni
les tests antigénique c'est une très
belle opportunité de nous aider à
maîtriser davantage l'épidémie alors que
nous travaillons à pouvoir rouvrir
progressivement les lieux de vie à
compter de la mi-mai pour que les
autotests fonctionne bien il faut que
nous puissions les utiliser de la bonne
manière
c'est à dire qu'il faut d'abord les
utiliser de façon régulière
le conseil scientifique dit au moins une
voire deux fois par semaine ensuite
chaque test lorsqu'il est positif doit
être confirmée par une pcr classique en
laboratoire pourquoi d'une barre pour
confirmer que le test est bien positif
parce qu'il peut y avoir des faux
positifs avec les autotests et surtout
et également pour qu'on maintienne notre
outil de suivi diagnostic et de
l'épidémie dans le pays
et enfin parce que ça permettra de
dépister s'il ya ou non un variant avec
ce test en aucun cas un autotest s'il
est négatif ne doit être considéré comme
un bon pour relâcher les gestes barrière
car là aussi le risque de faux négatifs
existe qui est un peu plus élevé qu'avec
les autres tests si par exemple vous
achetez une boîte d'autotest en
pharmacie qu vous réunissez entre amis
que tout le monde ce test que vous êtes
négatif sans doute le risque est il
moins important mais il n'est pas
impossible que l'un d'entre vous malgré
tout soit porteur du virus
et si vous faites absolument pas
attention aux gestes barrière alors vous
vous exposez quand même un risque de
contamination
nous déployons donc une stratégie qui
répond à cet objectif de dépistage ainsi
depuis le 12 avril
les autotests sont disponibles en vente
libre pour le grand public en pharmacie
d'officine
ils sont également pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie pour les aides à
domicile ainsi que les aidants familiaux
les travailleurs qui sont en contact de
personnes fragiles non vaccinées peuvent
se doter de ces auto test pris en charge
par l'assurance maladie à raison de 10
autotests part
danse et déjà vous êtes plus de cinq
cent mille à avoir acheté des autotests
en pharmacie et plus de 91 mille d'entre
eux ont été fournis gratuitement aux
travailleurs concernés
nous déployons également ses hôtes au
test pour aller chercher les publics qui
sont aujourd'hui encore en moyenne moins
testé que le reste de la population
je pense notamment au public précaire
qui font partie des publics les plus
éloignés aujourd'hui de nos dispositifs
de diagnostic et de dépistage c'est
pourquoi depuis le 12 avril
en ile de france nous avons lancé une
grande opération grande expérimentation
qui est porté par cette structure qui
distribue des autotests au sein des
accueils de jour des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence des campements
de gens du voyage où des campements roms
ce sont un demi million d'autos tests
qui seront distribués sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour couvrir ces populations
les plus précaires
dans un deuxième temps sept cent mille
autotests supplémentaires seront
déployés dans les quartiers prioritaires
de la ville pour permettre également
d'améliorer les capacités de dépistage
dans ces territoires en lien avec les
acteurs locaux en outre-mer également le
taux de dépistage est un peu en dessous
de la moyenne nationale et 200000
autotests ont d'ores et déjà été envoyés
dans ces territoires pour renforcer nos
capacités de dépistage enfin auprès des
jeunes et c'est jean michel blanquer qui
vous en parlera tout à l'heure pour les
écoliers et les étudiants en renfort de
la stratégie existante
porté par les tests salivaires un
dernier mot sur le diagnostic le
dépistage pour vous dire que nous
surveillons également étroitement la
progression des variants avec deux
méthodes
la première c'est une méthode
technologique qui s'appelle le
séquençage du génome viral qui se fait
dans des laboratoires très particulier
très spécifiques
la france a réalisé plus de quarante
quatre mille de ces séquençages depuis
le mois de février 2021
plus de 5000 la dernière semaine ce qui
nous place au troisième rang européen
le séquençage il est aussi très utile
pour à les identifier des nouveaux
variants si de nouveaux variants
apparaissait sur le territoire national
la deuxième méthode
c'est ce qu'on appelle le
ribes l'âge qui se fait en laboratoire à
partir des tests pcr réalisé et qui
permet d'identifier les variants les
plus connus le britannique
le sud-africain le brésilien également
et diagnosticable par cela et bientôt le
variant indien la technologie est en
train d'évoluer en ce sens ça nous
permet du coup d'adapter notre stratégie
d'abord de lutte contre le virus le
fameux tester alerté protéger en
renforçant considérablement les moyens
dans les territoires dans lesquels on
observe une circulation accrue de ces
variants mais ça nous permet également
d'adapter notre stratégie de vaccination
pour renforcer la protection des
populations
si nous devions identifiés tels ou tels
variant en concentration importante sur
un territoire donné
j'ai maintenant permettre de la
vaccination monsieur le premier ministre
alors pour préparer cette partie de la
conférence de presse j'avais plutôt
envie de répondre directement aux
questions que vous vous posez
alors avec mon équipe pour l'étaler les
chercher sur les réseaux sociaux
directement je ne tourne pas autour du
pot je commence par la question qui est
la plus posée mais qu'est ce qui se
passe avec le vaccin
astrazeneca astrazeneca c'est un vaccin
à l'action on ne peut plus classique en
matière de vaccination en cours depuis
des décennies d'emploi maladie c'est un
vaccin qui va stimuler votre système
immunitaire pour lui apprendre à
reconnaître le coronavirus si un jour il
devait être en contact avec vous ça
vaccin qui est très efficace vous le
savez et c'est tite deux injections
distante de 12 semaines comme d'autres
vaccins comme la plupart des vaccins
puis comme beaucoup de médicaments
d'ailleurs il peut donner ce qu'on
appelle des effets indésirables
passagers sans gravité dans moins de 10%
des cas vous pouvez avoir de la fièvre
ça passe avec du paracétamol rapidement
et sans complications dans de très rares
cas il peut provoquer des thromboses
c'est à dire la formation de petits
cailloux qui peuvent aller bouchée des
haines qui peuvent aller boucher la
circulation veineuse et provoquer pour
le coup des effets indésirables plus
graves mais ils sont très rares c'est
cinq cas environ pour un million de
personnes vaccinées
je vous donnais une comparaison si vous
prenez l'avion
pour traverser l'atlantique vous avez un
risque également de faire des thromboses
parce que vous allez être moins mobiles
et ce risque
si vous traversez l'atlantique en avion
il est 50 fois plus élevé que si vous
faites d'actionner par astra zeneca ça
permet quand même je crois de
relativiser les choses et je ne vous
parle même pas du risque que vous prenez
en ne vous vaccinant pas parce que c'est
sans comparaison
plusieurs pays proposent d'ailleurs ce
vaccin à tout le monde sans distinction
en france nous avons fait le choix de
limiter encore ce risque en ne proposant
le vaccin qu'aux français âgés de 55 ans
et plus est paradoxalement je constate
que cette mesure de précaution a pu
faire augmenter la méfiance
c'est tout le contraire de l'effet
recherché cela dit on parle beaucoup
trop à mon avis des personnes qui ne
veulent pas de ce vaccin est pas assez
des millions français qui sont déjà
vaccinés en astrazeneca plus de trois
quarts des vaccins livrés à la france
ont déjà été utilisés et encore
aujourd'hui près de 50 mille français
ont été vaccinés avec astrazeneca
d'ailleurs un autre argument qui ne
trompe pas ce sont les dizaines de
milliers de médecins de pharmaciens
d'infirmières d'infirmiers qui ont
commandé et continue de commander du
vaccin sera zeneca pour protéger leurs
patients
s'ils le font par définition c'est pour
leur bien bref nous continuons à
vacciner les personnes âgées de 55 ans
et plus avec un accès facilité en centre
notamment les week-ends pour certains
publics prioritaires tels qu enseignant
policiers professionnels de la petite
enfance est désormais aussi les
chauffeurs routiers chauffeurs de bus
taxis ou vtc livreurs les vendeurs de
produits ventes de produits alimentaires
etc
deuxième question qui nous est posée ma
mère a 80 ans c'est pas le cas de ma
mère et n'a toujours pas été vaccinés
est ce normal
alors non ce n'est pas normal en plus du
vaccin
astrazeneca en pharmacie en médecine de
ville voire au domicile grâce aux
infirmiers vous le savez toutes les
personnes âgées de 60 ans et plus ont
accès aux vaccins riser et moderna dans
l'un des mille 700 centres de
vaccination tenus par les cent cinquante
mille professionnels de santé pompiers
associations agents des collectivités
élus et que je salue
s'il n'y a pas encore eu de rendez-vous
de créneaux de rendez vous pour tout le
monde ça va venir
2 5 millions de français se font
vacciner chaque semaine dans notre pays
désormais le rythme va encore augmenter
à mesure que les livraisons vont elles
aussi augmenté
nous faisons tout pour vous donner de la
visibilité et vous permettre d'anticiper
vos rendez-vous aujourd'hui plus de 70%
des personnes âgées de 75 ans ont déjà
reçu au moins une injection de vaccin
c'est bien mais ça ne suffit pas nous
voulons protéger un maximum de personnes
âgées surtout celles qui sont trop
isolés pour savoir comment faire et
c'est pourquoi nous avons mobilisé les
maires les crs les associations pour ce
qu'on appelle des démarches d'aller vers
en complément nous avons demandé à
l'assurance maladie d'appeler toutes les
personnes âgées isolées non encore
vaccinés
plus de 350 mille appels ont déjà été
passées et nous continuerons puisque
notre objectif c'est 100% vacciner c'est
d'ailleurs déjà le cas dans les ehpad où
nous comptons désormais quasiment 100%
de vacciner enfin un numéro de téléphone
coupe-file dédiée aux personnes âgées
leur a été envoyé par sms ou par
courrier
troisième question où en est la
vaccination des soignants allez vous la
rendre obligatoire la situation là aussi
a bien évolué du côté des soignants plus
de 70 % près des trois quarts des
soignants ont reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin c'est même plus de 80% pour les
soignants lorsqu'ils ont plus de 50 ans
et les chiffres continuent de monter
chaque jour je le redis notre objectif
c'est 100% vacciner nous y arriverons
et la confiance paye une autre question
qui nous est posée mon épouse et
immunodéprimées j'ai peur de la
contaminer quand pourrais-je me faire
vacciner
quel que soit votre âge si vous êtes
majeur et que vous vivez sous le même
toit qu'une personne en situation
d'immunodépression sévère c'est le cas
de plusieurs centaines de milliers de
nos compatriotes la vaccination vous
sera ouverte à compter de lundi prochain
en astrazeneca si vous avez plus de 55
ans est on fire au moderna si vous avez
moins de 55 ans
notre question j'ai entendu qu'un
quatrième vaccin est disponible
oui il s'agit du vaccin johnsen qu'on
appelle aussi le dit angie qui authier
report des mécanismes bien connue donc
bien rodé il est effectivement
disponible
il est réservé pour le moment à tous les
français âgés de 55 ans et plus sans
condition les 200 premiers 200 mille
premiers vaccins sont livrés aux
pharmacies aux médecins aux infirmiers
libéraux qui pourront commencer à le
proposer à leurs patients à compter de
ce samedi
je rappelle que ce vaccin contrairement
aux autres ne nécessite qu'une seule
injection pour que vous soyez protéger
pas de rappel vaccinal pas de seconde
injection donc allez vous tenir votre
calendrier de vaccination vous avez
répondu monsieur le premier ministre je
vous confirme qu'on fait tout pour
et que nous avons la ferme intention de
tenir ses engagements ambitieux mais qui
sont à notre portée nous nous sommes ce
soir à 13 millions et demi de français
qui ont déjà reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin nous visons l'objectif des 20
millions à la mi mai des 30 millions à
la mi juin
et je vous rappelle que si vous avez
entre 50 et 60 ans vous pourrez prendre
rendez-vous en centre à compter de la
mi-mai
allez vous vacciner les enfants
là aussi c'est une question importante
mais je le dis elle n'est pas
d'actualité à l'heure à laquelle je vous
réponds notre objectif c'est de
continuer à protéger en priorité les
personnes les plus exposées aux formes
graves c'est-à-dire les populaires les
populations les plus âgés puis viendra
la population générale adulte
faudra-t-il dans un troisième temps
vacciner les enfants c'est une question
qui est abordé à l'échelle mondiale
d'une part à travers les études
scientifiques qui sont conduites par
tous pour déterminer si les vaccins sont
sûrs et efficaces pour les enfants des
premières données dont nous disposons la
réponse est oui
ensuite à l'échelle des pays à travers
les groupes d'experts qui travaillent
ces questions je vous répondrai quand
j'aurai les réponses à ces questions
mais vous avez compris que ce n'est pas
d'actualité pour le moment
enfin j'ai vu que l'obésité était un
facteur de risque de formes graves
ne faut-il pas à proposer la vaccination
aux personnes qui souffrent d'obésité
l'obésité est en effet un facteur de
risque de formes graves on en voit
beaucoup avec le premier ministre quand
on va dans les services de réanimation
j'ai donc saisi les comités
scientifiques pour déterminer quand et
dans quelles conditions nous pourrons
ouvrir la vaccination aux français qui
bien qu'ayant moins de 50 ans souffrent
d'obésité sévère
la réponse ne va pas tarder mais il est
probable que nous puissions là aussi
démarrer d'ici la mi-mai selon merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
j'invite le ministre de l'éducation
nationale à vous parler d'un sujet
d'actualité qui est le retour des
enfants à l'école lundi monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le premier ministre
comme mesdames messieurs comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur pas ministre les
enfants ont besoin de l'école et chacun
sait que c'est la politique que nous
avons poursuivi depuis notamment le
début de l'année scolaire de façon à
faire en sorte que les élèves de france
soit des élèves qui ne soient pas privés
d'école le but est fondamentale ça a été
dit c'est un but éducatif évidemment
mais aussi social psychologique
je crois que chaque famille de france le
sait l'école est fondamentale et la
crise sanitaire que nous vivons
peut-être permis de re découvrir
davantage cela elle est essentielle pour
tous les enfants et pour tous les
adolescents et c'est pour cette raison
que c'est notre priorité c'est pour
cette raison que la france a tenu bon
dans cette année scolaire 2020 21 et que
notre objectif reste le même jusqu'à la
fin de l'année scolaire
je voudrais pour commencer d'abord
adressé des remerciements à tous ceux
qui permettent cela je pense évidemment
aux professeurs à l'ensemble des
personnels de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi des collectivités locales nous
leur devons la reconnaissance cas c'est
grâce à elle est grâce à eux que nous
arrivons à cela aujourd'hui
vous avez aussi remercie les parents
d'élèves parce qu'il faut beaucoup de
sens de l'adaptation dans cette période
et finalement c'est notre solidarité
notre sens de l'union qui nous permet de
le faire cette coopération a donc permis
l'ouverture depuis septembre est elle
nous a conduit aussi à traverser ce mois
d'avril d'une manière particulière avec
et vacances qui ont été les mêmes pour
toutes la france et la semaine qui a
précédé
vacances avec les solutions que vous
connaissez je voudrais rappeler aussi
que pendant les vacances qui se termine
maintenant ses vacances du mois d'avril
au cours des deux semaines nous avons
accueilli jusqu'à 175 mille enfants par
jour dans le cadre de centres aérés ou
dans le cadre de l'école et c'est là
aussi quelque chose que nous devons à
des personnels que je veux remercier
ainsi que aux collectivités locales
alors comment s'organise cette rentrée
le premier ministre a commencé à le dire
nous sommes au rendez vous fixé
c'est-à-dire la possibilité la semaine
prochaine donc la semaine du 26 avril
d'avoir tous nos écoliers qui rentre à
l'école primaire avec leurs professeurs
bien sûr cela signifie donc on aura une
rentrée des élèves dès lundi prochain
tandis que pour l'enseignement
secondaire donc pour les collégiens et
les lycéens
ce sera un enseignement à distance il y
aura aussi je le signale au passage la
reprise des enseignements dans les
conservatoires pour les élèves des
premier et deuxième cycles inscrits dans
les classes à horaires aménagés
c'est avec la ministre de la culture
roselyne bachelot que ceux ci a été
établi il aura donc pour les collégiens
et pour les lycéens
un enseignement à distance dans la
semaine semaine qui a précédé les
vacances il y a eu des problèmes dans
certaines parties de la france et ça a
été particulièrement le cas le premier
jour c'est à dire le mardi
ces problèmes ont été vus avec les
régions de façon à ce que ce qu'on
appelle les environnements numériques de
travail soient pleinement opérationnels
avec leurs capacités qui a été augmentée
cela a été vu avec chaque région de
france même s'il devait y avoir des
problèmes à ce titre il y a de toute
façon le site ma classe à la maison qui
a été aussi renforcé dans de très
grandes proportions et je recommande
d'ailleurs que lorsqu'il y a des classes
numériques c'est à dire des classes à
distance cela se fasse avec ma classe à
la maison tandis que l'environnement
numérique de travail sert davantage pour
les échanges écrits avec les professeurs
cette semaine du 26 avril doit permettre
donc un retour de tous les 1
physiquement les écoliers les autres à
distance les collégiens et les lycéens
ensuite il y aura donc la semaine du 3
mai c'est le retour en classe pour les
collégiens et pour les lycéens
l'enseignement sera hybride en lycée
autrement dit il y aura ce que ont déjà
connu beaucoup de lycéens c'est à dire
un enseignement en 2011 la moitié des
lycéens qui viennent et l'autre ensuite
c'est selon un système qui est organisé
à l'échelle de chaque lycée on aura donc
un peu d'enseignement à distance là
aussi pour les lycéens concernés
s'agissant des collégiens ils rentrent
au collège normalement donc pleinement
simplement pour les élèves de 4e et de
3e des quinze départements les plus
touchés par l'épidémie que vous avez qui
doivent s'afficher qui sont le nord
l'aisne l'oise les yvelines la
seine-et-marne seine-saint-denis les
hauts-de-seine le val-d'oise le
val-de-marne l'essonne
paris la sarthe la loire le rhône et les
bouches du rhône
donc dans ces départements les élèves de
quatrième et de troisième seront aussi
en 2011 ensuite cette rentrée scolaire
du 3 mai permettra d'appliquer
l'ensemble des mesures que le premier
ministre et le ministre de la solidarité
et de la santé viennent d'évoquer je
vais y revenir maintenant
d'abord nous maintenons un protocole
sanitaires strictes
cela signifie que conformément à ce que
nous faisions juste avant le départ de
tous nous fermerons la classe dès qu'il
ya un cas de contamination
cette mesure est évidemment une mesure
très strictes elle conduira
nécessairement à ce qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de fermetures mais
évidemment il est largement préférable
d'avoir un pour cent des classes de
france qui ferment que d'avoir 100% des
écoles
donc nous serons amenés et parce que
nous le faisons depuis le début de la
rentrée scolaire à être pragmatique
c'est à dire à fermer lorsque un cas
existent nous maintenant évidemment les
mesures que vous connaissez tous
notamment le port du masque dès l'âge de
6 ans les gestes barrière renforcée
l'aération toutes les heures
la météo va permettre davantage cela
d'ailleurs nous encourageons les
collectivités pour les capteurs de co2
et les purificateurs d'air
cela fait d'ailleurs des mois que cela
s'est amorcée
selon des modalités qui varie d'un
endroit à l'autre nous sommes en
partenariat avec les collectivités
chaque fois que cela est pertinent nous
encourageons aussi les classes en plein
air de même que nous encourageons les
activités physiques et sportives en
plein air le plus possible et encore une
fois la saison le permet nous avons donc
le protocole auquel nous sommes habitués
qui s'accomplit je pense aussi à ce
qu'il a ce qui se passe pour les
cantines avec la possibilité chaque fois
que cela est nécessaire de faire en
sorte que les classes mangeons ensemble
de façon à limiter le brassage des
élèves il y a par ailleurs et c'est un
point fort pour l'ensemble de la france
est aussi évidemment pour le système
scolaire
le système testé alerté protégé qui est
considérablement renforcé pour cette
nouvelle période
vous savez nous avons eu une première
période c'était au premier trimestre où
nous utilisions donc les tests
antigénique et ceci a permis de rompre
des chaînes de contamination notamment
d'ailleurs pour les élèves de
l'enseignement secondaire
au deuxième trimestre nous avons
développé les tests salivaires ces tests
salivaires vont se déployer encore plus
pour l'école primaire en particulier
nous allons passer à une utilisation de
300 mille tests salivaires c'était le
nous étions légèrement en dessous de 300
milles au moment du départ de tous pour
aller vers 600 mille tests salivaires
hebdomadaire c'est évidemment très
important pour les collégiens nous
utiliserons aussi des tests salivaires
et en fonction de ce que dira la haute
autorité de santé le premier ministre
l'a dit tout à l'heure et bien nous
aurons aussi éventuellement les
autotests pour les collégiens enfin pour
les lycéens
il y aura aussi des autotests c'est au
total seront donc distribués dans les
lycées il y aura un autotest par semaine
je rappelle qu'une récente étude
scientifique nous a montré que si cela a
été bien fait nous pouvions diminuer les
contaminations de 50% par cette pratique
est bien pour les lycéens donc cette
auto test aura lieu une fois par semaine
la semaine du 3 mai sera l'occasion
d'avoir des activités pédagogiques
autour de cela il y aura des tutoriels
des personnels formés pour expliquer aux
élèves ce geste simple qui que l'on a à
pratiquer lorsque l'on fait les
autotests et tout ceci sera donc
pleinement opérationnel pour que les
lycéens ne puisse le faire dans des
lieux dédiés dans le lycée à partir de
la semaine du 10 mai enfin pour les
personnels chaque personnel travaillant
dans les établissements et dans les
écoles recevra deux tests par semaine
qui pourront être faits à la maison ce
sera gratuit évidemment
et tout ceci est en train d'être
distribuées dans les soixante mille
écoles collèges et lycées de france de
façon à ce que tous les personnels
puissent la voir
je rappelle que c'est environ 50
millions d'autos test que nous allons
ainsi déployé au mois de mai et juin
pour cette stratégie tester alerté
protéger c'est évidemment un élément clé
pour arriver à tout simplement mieux
protéger nos élèves et l'ensemble de
ceux qui travaillent à l'école et bien
entendu ceci va de pair avec la
stratégie vaccinale qui vient de vous
être exposés et par le premier ministre
et par le ministre des solidarités et de
la santé voudrais simplement dire que
évidemment nous compterons continuons à
travailler aux principes d'étape de
vaccination des professeurs les
professeurs de plus de 55 ans cela a été
rappelé et font l'objet de centres de
vaccination dédiés c'est vrai aussi
d'ailleurs pour les forces de police
donc ce système continue de continuera
le week-end prochain
moi même puisque j'ai 56 ans j'irai me
faire vacciner avec le vaccin
astrazeneca illustrant ainsi ce que
viennent bien olivier vers ans de façon
à ce que nous puissions bien montrer que
ce vaccin est sûr et qu'il fait partie
de la stratégie de vaccination
d'autres vagues suivront notamment
bientôt pour les professeurs de plus de
50 en s'occupant d'enfants handicapés ou
travailler en école maternelle et ceux
ci sera évidemment précisé
en fonction de la stratégie vaccinale
général ensuite nous continuerons à
travailler pour que toutes les classes
ouvertes puisse effectivement avoir lieu
même quand il y a des absents je
rappelle que nous recrutons 5000
remplaçant actuellement pour les cas
d'absence qui excède nos capacités de
remplacement habitués
enfin je voudrais terminer en évoquant
des enjeux de l'enseignement supérieur
évidemment vu par la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
mais qui sont dans la continuité de ce
que j'ai pu dire d'abord parce qu'il y
aura aussi les diffusions d'autotest
dans les universités et puis ensuite
parce que je n'ignore pas qu'il irait
évidemment de nombreuses questions qui
sont posées autour des enjeux des
examens qui concerne aussi bien
l'enseignement secondaire que
l'enseignement supérieur les
informations les plus précises sont
données sur nos sites internet je ne
rentre pas dans dans tous les détails
mais comme vous le savez dans la période
actuelle qui s'achève le 2 mai les
examens ont été reportés chaque fois que
possible et souvent remplacé quand
c'était possible par des examens à
distance au delà de cette période
nous voulons assurer des examens en
présence en assurant des conditions
sanitaires strictes
cette possibilité nous le faisons au
service de nos élèves et de nos
étudiants c'est l'intérêt de nos élèves
et de nos étudiants d'avoir un mélange
de contrôle continu et de contrôle
terminal
c'est ainsi que le brevet se passe à la
fin de la troisième est maintenu en tant
que tel c'est ainsi aussi que le
baccalauréat comporte une part de
contrôle continu et une part de contrôle
terminal
nous maintenons donc les deux épreuves
de contrôle terminal prévu c'est à dire
les écrits de philosophie et l'épreuve
du grand oral qui auront lieu donc à la
fin du mois de juin là encore je le
redis si nous faisons cela c'est pour le
bien des élèves pour les entraîner à ce
type d'exercice
et pour qu'il ya un équilibre entre la
note de contrôle continu et la note de
contrôle terminal
il en va de même pour ceux qui
présentent des concours comme les élèves
des classes préparatoires qui
présenteront leur concours à la fin de
cette année il en va de même aussi pour
les étudiants de bts c'est un sujet dont
j'ai été beaucoup saisie je voudrais
m'adresser tout particulièrement puisque
j'ai bien compris qu'il y avait parfois
un malaise pour certains d'entre eux qui
se sentent même parfois mal préparé du
fait des circonstances et je voudrais
dire donc quelques éléments sur ce point
le premier c'est que bien entendu nous
sommes capables de prendre en
considération les situations
particulières
chaque bts est un cas particulier
notamment dans les lycées publics le les
bts se sont rompues la plupart du temps
être présents ne parfois à plein temps
parfois à mi temps dans ces lycées dans
d'autres structures ça n'a pas été le
cas
c'est pour cette raison que pour tenir
compte parfois de ses poèmes de
préparation frédéric vidal appui annoncé
la semaine dernière que nous faisions
une session de rattrapage
cela signifie donc que les épreuves de
bts prévu au mois de mai auront lieu
mais que pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas
y aller parce qu'ils seraient malades ou
qui échoueraient à cette épreuve il aura
une session de rattrapage au début du
mois de juillet cette session de
rattrapage consistera en euros et ses
oraux pourront être préparés
spécifiquement en mai et juin
nous dégageons les moyens
supplémentaires pour qu'il ya un apple
compagne mans personnalisé de chaque
élève
là aussi si nous faisons cela c'est pour
garantir la valeur des diplômes
c'est en ayant à l'esprit l'intérêt des
élèves et des étudiants c'est à dire la
possibilité non seulement d'assurer la
valeur du diplôme et aussi de bien les
entraîner pour les épreuves en question
bien sûr je ne saurais rentrer
maintenant dans tous les détails mais il
est très important de redire à quel
point pour les élèves de l'enseignement
secondaire comme les étudiants de
l'enseignement supérieur
notre préoccupation c'est qu'ils
puissent avoir les conditions les plus
normale possible et que nous préparions
leur avenir ce qui passe aussi parfois
par la prise en compte et du contrôle
continu et du contrôle terminal
enfin je conclurai en parlant des
activités physiques et sportives
travailler avec roxana maracineanu vous
le savez dans cette période si
particulière pour les enfants et les
adolescents comme pour le reste de la
population d'ailleurs il ya un enjeu de
santé et de bien-être à avoir des
activités physiques
c'est pourquoi nous les encourageons à
l'école primaire au collège au lycée et
pour les étudiants
et puis nous avons tenu à ce que pendant
les vacances les clubs sportifs soient
ouverts aux mineurs pour les pratiques
en extérieur cette règle va donc rester
en vigueur pour les semaines suivantes
et dès que ce sera possible nous
essaierons de desserrer les contraintes
sanitaires pour permettre la reprise des
activités en intérieur mais nous n'y
sommes pas encore donc voilà mesdames et
messieurs monsieur le premier ministre
ce que nous pouvons dire pour les
éléments de préparation de la rentrée je
rappelle que pour toutes les questions
plus précises il y a ce qu'on appelle
les questions fréquemment posées pour
lesquels il ya des réponses sur le site
du ministère education.gouv.fr et bien
entendu tout au long des prochains jours
nous continuerons à préciser le
déroulement de chacun de ces éléments
je vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur
misé ducasse nationale j'invite
maintenant à s'exprimer gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs ça
fait plus d'un an que collectivement
tous les français sont des efforts
importants mais ils reportent leurs
déplacements ils ne vont pas voir leurs
proches et nous savons à quel point cela
coûte à chacun d'entre nous ses efforts
comme viens de l'expliquer monsieur le
premier ministre commence à payer sur le
sol national
mais comme l'a expliqué monsieur
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
dans d'autres pays les variants se
développe il ne faudrait pas que leur
développement leur diffusion
jean réduire à néant les efforts faits
par l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
c'est pourquoi face à la progression des
variants et notamment des drian dix
brésiliens et sud africain nous avons
pris dès le début de l'année des mesures
fortes pour prévenir et réduire leur
diffusion
depuis la fin du mois de janvier nous
avons restreint fortement les
possibilités de venir en france pour les
voyageurs en provenance des pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne
depuis le début janvier seuls les
ressortissants français et européens
ainsi que les personnes justifiant d'un
motif impérieux peuvent venir sur notre
sol ils doivent tous justifier d'un test
pcr négatif de -2 72 heures et s'engager
à leur arrivée en france à s'isoler
pendant sept jours
mais face à l'aggravation de la
situation sanitaire brésil en inde et
dans d'autres pays
nous avons décidé de prendre des mesures
plus drastiques de lutte contre les
diffusion du virus et de ces variants
très vite dès le mercredi 14 avril
nous avons suspendu les vols depuis le
brésil mais nous savons que l'arrêt des
liaisons aériennes 9 qu'une protection
partielle
une telle mesure peut conduire à la
multiplication évidemment de voie de
contournement dans la durée
des vols restent nécessaires pour
quelques situations limites et notamment
s'agissant de nos compatriotes français
d'étrangers la suspension des vols ne
peut donc pas être une mesure
généralisée et durable
la meilleure protection contre les
variants et la mise en place d'un
sanitaire à l'arrivée sur notre
territoire nous mettrons donc en place à
compter de samedi matin ce sas sanitaire
avec un dispositif de quarantaine
signifie qu'ils significativement
renforcée dix jours pour tous les
voyageurs en provenance des pays où la
situation sanitaire est jugée
inquiétante du fait de la cyclo
circulation de ces variants cpi soit ce
jour le brésil le chili l'argentine
l'afrique du sud et l'inde
et comme l'a dit monsieur le premier
ministre cette histoire évoluer si cela
est nécessaire
les motifs pour venir en france depuis
ces pays seront donc encore réduit pour
l'essentiel seuls les ressortissants
français et les européens ayant leur
résidence principale en france pourront
entrer sur le territoire national les
passagers en provenance de ces pays
devront tout d'abord se soumettre à
plusieurs exigences renforcées
d'abord ils devront justifier au départ
de leur vol d'un test pcr négative de
moins de 36 heures et non plus de moins
de 72 heures à l'arrivée sur le sol
français tous les passagers seront
systématiquement testés à nouveau avec
un test antigénique en plus du test
systématique tous les passagers en
provenance de ces pays et quel que soit
le résultat de leurs tests qu'ils soient
positifs ou négatifs et nous l'imaginons
les négatifs seront la grande majorité
des cas feront l'objet d'une mise en
quarantaine de dix jours décidée par
arrêté préfectoral pour que la
quarantaine soit respectée il faut
qu'elle soit évidemment contrôler c'est
pourquoi nous avons décidé le
renforcement très fort des contrôles des
personnes mises en quarantaine premier
contrôle celui du lieu de la quarantaine
il sera contrôlé au départ et à
l'arrivée des personnes qui viennent de
ces pays au départ tout d'abord avant
l'embarquement les passagers devront
déclarer à la compagnie aérienne le lieu
dans lequel ils effectueront leur
quarantaine en france ils devront pour
cela désormais
fournir un justificatif attestant de
l'existence de ce lieu un justificatif
de domicile par exemple une réservation
d'hôtel mais aussi sa compatibilité avec
les exigences sanitaires et notamment
son accès par les forces de l'ordre
la compagnie aérienne pourra refuser aux
voyageurs d'embarquer si ces
justificatifs apportées ne sont pas
jugés probants à l'arrivée ces
justificatifs seront à nouveau contrôlés
par les agents de la police aux
frontières de la république deuxième
contrôle après celui de la quarantaine
celui du respect des règles de la
quarantaine est sortie autorisée par la
quarantaine seront réduites
aujourd'hui pour faire ses courses par
exemple les gens peuvent sortir de leur
domicile pour des motifs notamment
impérieux certes ils seront désormais
limitées entre 10 heures du matin et
midi
en dehors de ces horaires la personne en
quarantaine pourra faire l'objet à tout
moment d'un contrôle sur le lieu de
quarantaine qu'elle a déclaré par
ailleurs ce sont désormais les forces de
l'ordre qui seront chargés de contrôler
la personne mise en quarantaine les
policiers et les gendarmes se rendront
au domicile de cette personne à l'hôtel
qu'elle a déclaré pour vérifier qu'elles
respectent bien son isolement
si les policiers et gendarmes constatent
que cette personne ne respecte pas les
règles de quarantaine une amende qui est
entre 1000 et 1500 euros sera dressé
contre 135 euros
aujourd'hui au delà des contrôles nous
mettons en place un dispositif
d'accompagnement les agents de
l'assurance maladie que monsieur le
ministre la santé et la solidarité ger
seron à titre exemple chargé du suivi
sanitaire des personnes mises en
quarantaine toutes ces mesures
s'appliqueront donc samedi matin les
règles relatives aux tests et à la
quarantaine renforcer s'applique
également aux voyageurs en provenance de
guyane par ailleurs et j'en terminerai
par là le gouvernement soumettra au
parlement dans le cadre du débat relatif
au projet de loi sur la sortie du régime
l'état d'urgence une disposition visant
à renforcer davantage
ce dispositif de quarantaine
concrètement il sera proposé d'ouvrir la
possibilité aux pouvoirs publics
d'imposer un lieu de quarantaine dans
les cas rare sans doute où le voyageur
le lieu choisi par le voyageur ne permet
pas un isolement efficace et un contrôle
effectif par les forces de police
nous devons donc tout mettre en oeuvre
pour protéger les français de toute
recrudescence de l'épidémie dans le
respect de notre droit du débat
démocratique
j'ajoute que jean-baptiste lemoyne le
secrétaire d'état chargé notamment de
nos compatriotes à l'étranger est
pleinement mobilisé pour que ces
derniers dans les pays les plus
fortement touchés soit évidemment
accompagné chanteur aime ce premier pour
remercier très sincèrement l'ensemble
des forces de l'ordre de notre pays qui
depuis plus d'un an sont mobilisés pour
faire respecter ces règles sanitaires
elles le seront vous le savez encore
mobilisés pour ces prochains jours ces
prochaines semaines et pour protéger
tous les français merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre je me rendrai en
début de semaine avec le ministre de
l'intérieur et le ministre chargé des
transports dans un aéroport pour nous
assurer de l'effectivité des la mise en
oeuvre des mesures que nous venons de
décider
mes chers concitoyens les efforts que
nous avons consentis vont produire leurs
effets à une condition cependant dont
tout le reste dépend rester vigilants et
mobilisés tenir autant que nécessaire ne
rien lâcher trop tôt au risque de tout
compromettre
adopter une stratégie prudente et
progressive prendre toutes les
dispositions face au risque de
résurgence et de mutation du virus y
protéger les plus vulnérables et les
plus jeunes
continuez à donner la priorité à l'école
et à l'éducation
soutenir et accompagner notre économie
encore et toujours les secteurs les plus
impactés et l'ensemble des français
autant de temps qu'il le faudra
anticiper les étapes à venir dans un
cadre concerté
cette crise sanitaire et toutes ses
conséquences nous met à rude épreuve et
je salue votre courage votre résistance
et l'indispensable respect par l'immense
majorité d'entre vous des restrictions
diverses que la situation nous impose de
prendre en cet instant je pense à toutes
celles et ceux qui sont morts là que
vides à leurs proches et à nos
concitoyens qui emportent des séquelles
durables mais je sais aussi que nous
avons de vrais motifs d'espoir nous
progressons grâce à la solidarité
collective et au déploiement massif de
la vaccination des perspectives
nouvelles s'offrent à nous et nous
sommes déterminés à franchir chacune des
étapes qui nous conduiront j'en suis sûr
à 1 était le plus normale possible
cela dépend de nous tous je vous
remercie et je suis prêt avec ministre à
répondre à vos questions
on se forme ce prêt ministre de bria
pour l' agence france-presse
respect ces prémisses vous avez parlé de
redonner aux vertus repart donc par
étape prudente et progressive
qu'en est il du couvre feu peut-on
imaginer que le couvre-feu est venue dès
le mois de mai peut-être par territoire
est-ce qu'il va disparaître tout
simplement ou être plus tard et puis une
deuxième question sur le progrès de la
vaccination
peut-on imaginer que à terme lorsque les
populations de moins de 55 ans seront
éligibles
est-ce qu'elle pourrait être elle aussi
à nouveau éligible à l'astra zeneca
notamment si on se rendait compte que
les stocks disponibles n'étaient pas
suffisamment utilisé par les seules plus
de 55 ans jour merci merci
bonjour monsieur le produit soit c'est
angers pour tf1 lci
vous envisagez des réouvertures
territoriales est-ce que très
concrètement ça veut dire que si dans
certains départements la situation n'est
pas bonne
à la mi mai les terrasses les musées
dans ces départements la pourrait ne pas
ouvrir et sans dévoiler le calendrier
des réouvertures n'a compris que ce
n'était pas l'objet ce soir est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un mot sur la
méthode est ce qu'il y aura des critères
sanitaires précis pour dire si et dans
tel ou tel département on peut commencer
les réouvertures par exemple est-ce que
vous allez reprendre à votre compte le
critère de 5000 nouveaux cas par jour
qui avait été évoqué en décembre par le
président de la république je vous
remercie monsieur misa santé s'il veut
bien mais rouge en va pour une troisième
question et ensuite on va répondre à ce
1er juin jour pour bfm tv
certains commerces par mais moi
l'expression je sais que vous ne
l'apprécié pas trop dit non essentiels
ont demandé dans une tribune ce matin à
rouvrir dès le 10 mai seriez vous prêt à
avancer le calendrier de réouverture
pour ses commerces et une question sur
l'éducation
que faire par exemple si un lycéen
refusent de pratiquer un autotest très
bien merci beaucoup
alors je vais répondre à deux des
questions que je cède la parole aux mini
jacente et aux mises et le cash
nationale s'il veut bien ensuite relayée
d'abord le couvre feu par question sous
couvre-feu à 19 heures je le rappelle il
est d'abord je commence à le dire
maintenue et il sera maintenue jusqu'à
nouvel ordre et nous verrons à la mi mai
étape suivante où en sera la situation
épidémique
c'est clair donc il n'y a pas
d'automaticité à la levée du couvre feu
y compris à cet échange parce qu'en
ville veut dire je souhaite que nous
poursuivions fermement et nettement les
évolutions qui sont à l'oeuvre depuis
plusieurs jours mais en l'état des
données à ma disposition des à
disposition du pays
je considère que je ne peux pas faire
cette annonce ce ne serait pas prudent
j'ajoute que je réponds à la question
d'un journaliste de bfm tv dont les
produits de première nécessité on ne
parle plus de d'essentiel ou non
essentiels là aussi cela a été indiqué
c'est également alléchant autour de la
mi mai que nous pourrons envisager la
réouverture de ces commerces
bon alors voilà j'ai lu comme vous dis
mais me mais vous conviendrez avec moi
que ce n'est quand même pas extrêmement
éloignée enfin la question sur la
territorialisation qui avait du reste
d'ailleurs été évoquée par le ministre
des solidarités de la santé vous l'avez
entendu je pense je n'ai précisé
d'ailleurs à deux reprises dans mon
intervention
d'abord je manière nous n'avons jamais
été fermé par principe à la
territorialisation des mesures pour pour
la question posée ou pour tout autre
nous l'avons d'ailleurs pratiqué et nous
n'excluons pas d'y recourir
vous vous en connaissez alors plutôt que
là je pense qu'on a fait des progrès
plutôt que de dire un chiffre en valeur
absolue sur le niveau d'abord c'est une
batterie de critères
et puis c'est autant une tendance que
nous prenons désormais en considération
le ministre l'expliquerai mieux que moi
qu'un chiffres en valeur absolue ou
conseils précis est d'ailleurs observé
dans l'intervention du ministre de
l'éducation nationale que s'agissant un
des jauges dans les collèges c'est bien
ce qui a été précisé
nous le ferions sur une base
territorialisée et il a d'ailleurs cité
les départements correspondant monsieur
le ministre des solidarités la première
question portait sur le vaccin
astrazeneca et les moins de 55 ans si je
résume sait si vous avez vacciner tous
les plus de 55 ans qu'il vous reste des
vaccins astrazeneca est ce que vous
allez rendre accessible aux moins de 55
ans alors je vous dirais que encore une
fois la logique la façon avec laquelle
nous procédons depuis le début c'est
celle qui consiste à agir en toute
sécurité et en toute efficacité pour
protéger les français
la france a suspendu pendant trois jours
le vaccin contre s'était posé des
questions au niveau européen souvenez
vous on m'avait d'ailleurs nous avait
reproché d'avoir peut être surréagi
et puis ensuite sur avis de la haute
autorité de santé nous avons limité
l'usagé ce vaccin en attendant des
résultats qui complémentaire de des
années visées européennes en plus de 55
ans je vous faire une réponse du gascon
mais si les autorités européennes et ou
nationales nous disent que sur la base
des millions et des millions et des
millions de personnes vaccinées en
astrazeneca on peut désormais le
proposer aux personnes plus jeunes on
suivra les recommandations
si l inverse à nous disent on peut pas
l'utiliser chez les personnes plus
jeunes on utilisera évidemment pas chez
les personnes plus jeunes tout existe en
europe un des pays qui le font sans
limite d'âge
d'autres qui le font sans limite d'âge
comme l'allemagne mais en faisant signer
un consentement sur les cédera nous
encore une fois comme on est dans une
stratégie de protection des publics les
plus âgés parce qu'on n'est pas assez
quand on a 50 50 mais quand comment
fonctionne par tranche d'âge dégressifs
pour l'instant la question ne se pose
pas donc si elle devait exploser mais ce
serait sur des bases sanitaires et on
encore une fois la sécurité avant tout
le reste
sur la question comment empêcher de vous
dire ce que c'est la question est ce que
vous allez parce qu'on voulait pas
rouvrir une semaine plus tôt jeux jeux à
brion un certain nombre de conférences
de presse maintenant à mon actif je me
souviens qu'on était passé une fois
d'une conférence de presse on dit est ce
que pourquoi est ce que voulait pas
rouvrir un peu plus tôt la semaine
d'après ce que vous n'avez pas rouvert
un peu trop tôt encore une fois on ouvre
au bon moment au bon endroit
si les indicateurs sanitaires nous
permet de le faire en confiance rien ne
serait pire que de relâcher un certain
nombre de mesures de freinage pour de
voir les remettre une semaine ou deux
semaines plus tard et c'est pas ça peut
arriver des pays très très bien on était
obligé de le faire encore une fois
l'allemagne pour une re la cité mais
d'autres pays ça peut arriver
donc il faut qu'on soit dans une
dynamique dans une trajectoire de
réduction du nombre de cas qu'on sache
qu'on est sur la bonne voie comme nous
l'avons été il ya un an
comme nous l'avons été cet automne et là
on peut commencer
en restant vigilant a relâché un certain
nombre de mesures de frenchy non pardon
pour l'expression mais on va se faire
plaisir on va rouvrir des choses et on
va on va constater une semaine dix jours
aux quinze jours plus tard qu'il faut
refermer et là je ne suis pas sûr que
l'acceptabilité soit meilleur ni pour
les personnes pour les commerçants
concert
n'est ni pour les français donc on tient
bon encore un peu ensemble et après on
arrivera à retrouver un peu plus de
liberté plus de vie on en a tous
absolument envie et on a tous absolument
besoin sur la question que vous aviez
posé après c'était une question je crois
sur les autotests lycéens refusent
l'autotest on appelle jean michel
blanquer votre sympathique remarques sur
mon âge me sioniste d'un santé ne
conduit à vous souhaiter un bon
anniversaire
j'avais j'ai dû casser nationale merci
monsieur le premier ministre sur les
autotests des lycéens le ce qui
s'applique c'est ce qui s'applique pour
l'ensemble des tests et notamment pour
les mineurs c'est à dire c'est forcément
avec l'accord donc en l'occurrence
l'accord delà de la famille c'est vrai
pour les tests salivaires à l'école
primaire c'est vrai pour les tests génie
que nous pratiquions et c'est vrai aussi
pour ses nouveaux hôtes aux tests mais
je voudrais profiter de votre question
pour dire que ces auto test non ne
représente aucun caractère vraiment
invasif et aucune douleur
al'inverse des tests auxquels nous
sommes maintenant habitués les tests
dits naso pharyngé donc c'est très
simple à faire
ça ne fait pas mal du tout et donc nous
escomptons que l'ensemble des lycéens le
fasse avec l'accord de leurs familles
parce que c'est dans l'intérêt de chacun
et 100 dans l'intérêt de tous c'est
assez simple d'usagé mais dès demain
nous diffuserons les tutoriels qui
montre comment comment l'on fait et il y
aura des personnels spécialisés des
personnels volontaires pour accompagner
les lycéens quand il le feront dans
l'établissement nous ferons une
évaluation de cela dès la première
semaine donc la semaine du 10 mai donc
deuxième semaine de la rentrée pour
physique pour les lycéens mais qui sera
là la première semaine de mise en oeuvre
des autotests pour eux et ce bilan nous
conduira à voir si on continue à le
faire en lycée ou si on peut proposer
aux lycéens de le faire de faire à la
maison
s'agissant des adultes je le redis ils
le font à la maison et donc nous
l'offrons de test des autotests par
personne jusqu'à jusqu'aux vacances
d'été
allez un dernier jeu de questions si
vous voulez bien le premier ministre
messieurs les ministres flamands tardive
pour seignosse du groupe canal+ deux
questions une première sur la
vaccination
allez-vous avancer le calendrier de
vaccination pour permettre à l'ensemble
des français de pouvoir se faire
vacciner on sait que d'ici la mi mai
normalement les personnes les plus à
risque auront reçu au moins une
injection et puis deuxième question pour
vous monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
vous avez évoqué notamment la période
des examens de fin de cycle est ce que
vous pourriez demander à l'ensemble des
élèves de se faire tester peut-être
grâce à ses hôtes au test avant les
examens et qu'en est il pour un élève
qui serait cas positifs ou qu'à
contacter au lycée ou au collège peut-il
est bien passé des épreuves dans un
second temps peut-être de rattrapage ou
est-ce qu'on prendrait en compte le
contrôle continu
merci beaucoup merci
les moissons pour france télévisions
avec la fermeture des écoles il ya trois
semaines une tolérance pour s'isoler
avait été observée ce week-end si l'on
rentre de confinement notamment pour des
retours à l'école pourra-t-on
concrètement être verbalisés et ma
deuxième question porte sur la guyane
pardon les restrictions de voyages vers
ce dépôt vers ce territoire d'outre-mer
ne sont impliqués que dans un sens pour
l'instant pour protéger les guyanais ne
vous est il pas appliquer ces
restrictions dans l'autre sens également
ses premiers ministres bonsoir boris
karlamoff pour l'agencé de prl alors on
a bien compris ce soir que vous nous
donnerez pas de liste des établissements
qui seraient susceptibles d'ouvrir mi
mai mais certains d'entre eux ont besoin
de temps pour préparer leur réouverture
donc je tente quand même ma chance est
ce que les cinémas les théâtres pourront
rouvrir à la mi mai et d'en cas échéant
à partir de quand serez vous en mesure
de leur donner une date pour fixer leurs
leur réouverture merci très bien donc je
vais d'abord demandé au ministre de la
santé de revenir pour le calendrier de
vaccination ensuite mise éducation et
vie intérieure et pendant que ministre
se prépare je réponds à la toute
dernière question donc non pas ce soir
de liste toutefois comment vous dire les
établissements que vous avez cités
pourraient être concernés d'accord et
nous avons bien et roselyne bachelot en
l'espèce des discussions extrêmement
approfondie avec eux pour connaître
leurs impératifs
c'est à dire en particulier la date à
partir de laquelle ils devraient être
informés de la décision qui sera
définitivement prise donc tout ça est
bien connu les protocoles sont quasiment
finalisé et les concertations se
poursuivre j'espère encore une fois
que nous puissions mettre en mesure de
faire des annonces plus précises comme
je voulais dire c'est rapidement
monsieur le ministre de la santé j'ai
pardon je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris
la teneur de la question qui consistait
à savoir s'ils ont avancé le calendrier
vaccinal en fait le calendrier vaccinal
encore une fois il est fondé sur un la
protection des personnes qui sont un
risque de faire des formes graves ou par
catégorie d'âge là ce sont les 60 70 ans
qui peuvent désormais se faire vacciner
et les plus de 55 ans en astrazeneca et
entre en scène à partir de la mi mai ce
sont les plus de 50 ans on y ajoute
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de publics
vulnérables j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
des gens qui ont une obésité qui est
sévère tout cela représente des millions
et des millions de français qui vont
devoir avoir besoin de plusieurs
semaines pour avoir un rendez-vous et
pour pouvoir être vaccinés en bonne et
due forme et donc plus nous avons de
livraison de vaccins
on a parfois des très bonnes nouvelles
c'était le cas la semaine dernière avec
été dose de de pfizer supplémentaires ou
plus on a le vaccin qui arrivent plus
orexine vite et tôt on sait faire quand
il était quand on était à 50 milles
vaccination jours on était à 50 milles
quand on a eu quand il fallait qu'on en
fasse 500 milles par jour on y monte à
500 1000 et s'il faut qu'on monte à 1
million
on montera un million on sait faire donc
vraiment on aider on est on est
dépendante à et notre calendrier
calendrier qu'on vous a indiqué encore
une fois ambitieuse et donc on n'a pas
de marge particulière il faut qu'on
puisse vacciner les français avec les
vaccins que nous avons et par catégories
d'âge et de vulnérabilité ensuite ce
sera le temps de la population générale
c'est à dire que toutes les personnes
qui n'ont donc pas d'aidé risque majoré
de faire des formes graves
merci une seule mise éducation pour les
sujets très importants des examens mais
un s'agissant des examens et concours
ils font l'objet d'un protocole
sanitaire
d'ailleurs certains examens et concours
sont programmés à l'heure actuelle pour
la période dans laquelle dans laquelle
nous sommes et parfois j'entends
certains à réclamer des annulations
d'examens ou de concours alors même que
ce que ça représente physiquement comme
activité ne peut être beaucoup moins
contaminant que bien des choses que nous
faisons que nous faisons tous les jours
puisque ces examens et concours et
hendaye en moins nombreux cette année
nous avons des disponibilités de sa la
possibilité de créer de la distance
entre chacun et de prendre toute une
série de mesures en matière de gestes
barrières qui permettent de le faire en
tout en toute sérénité
donc c'est ce qui présidera par exemple
à l'organisation de l'épreuve de
philosophie écrite au baccalauréat pour
prendre cet exemple
à ce stade nous n'avons pas prévu de
demander un test négatif comme lorsqu'on
fait un voyage pour pour faire un examen
bien sûr c'est des sujets sur lesquels
on peut éventuellement évoluer même si
ça pose la question vous avez posé pose
un problème juridique particulier donc a
priori ce n'est pas cela qui est prévu
mais c'est vrai que nous sommes
pragmatiques c'est à dire nous regardons
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
on pourrait renforcer les conditions
sanitaires qu au moment de la
réalisation de ces examens mais à ce
stade ce n'est pas alors ce point là
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
merci beaucoup monsieur vis l'appel de
miser intérieur pour les questions sur
le week-end et la guyane
ah oui ni indication un roman mais
j'aime vraiment ce qu'ils avaient une
dimension de votre question que je n'ai
pas abordés c'est à dire vous avez
demandé le rattrapage si on était malade
excusez moi donc le
vous l'avez vu l'année dernière nous
avons été capables d'organiser une
session de rattrapage du baccalauréat
beaucoup plus ample que d'habitude est
beaucoup plus ouverte que d'habitude ça
s'est passé en septembre d'ailleurs sans
que son qu'il y ait beaucoup de
commentaire parce que ça s'est passé
très bien cette année ce sera pareil
c'est à dire que bien entendu notre
objectif c'est toujours la bienveillance
vis-à-vis des élèves et des étudiants de
ce que nous voulons c'est la réussite
évidemment de chacun mais la réussite à
partir de bain d'un véritable examen et
donc oui un élève qui aurait été absent
parce que malade
évidemment on aura droit à une session
de rattrapage
et c'est vrai pour chacun mais des
examens dont nous parlons ben là je vous
remercie
merci celui des intérieurs oui très
rapidement nous protégeons nos
compatriotes en guyane évidemment le
ministre d outre mer y est
particulièrement attentifs et nous
mettons déjà en place un ensemble de
mesures pour les arrivées sur le
territoire guyanais comme d'ailleurs
dans le reste de l'autre mère ce qui a
de différent peut-être dans
l'association d'aujourd'hui c'est que
évidemment le variant brésilien du fait
de la frontière qui est grande et qui
est difficile à maîtriser avec les
autres pays du continent sud-américain
et singulièrement avec le brésil fait
que c'est évidemment mais une
multiplication possible de varier au
brésilien auprès la population guyanaise
des communautés pas pour nous imaginent
abl d'empêcher à des français les
guyanais devenir ce territoire national
nous leur donnons la possibilité de
venir avec comme tous les autres
territoires extérieurs à la métropole
ces mesures de quarantaine
évidemment les citoyens français peuvent
revenir sur le sol métropolitain
quand ils le souhaitent sur la question
du week-end de tolérance oui il sera en
parallèle du week-end de tolérance des
départs mais à la condition qu'il s'agit
de revenir avec les enfants pour voir
les ramener si j'ose dire dans les
casses et déscolarisé à partir de lundi
donc je demanderai au préfet que je
réunis demain de pouvoir continuer
évidemment les contrôles l'otan montrent
qu'il s'agit du rassemblement
seulement le beau temps nous en
profitons sans doute tous mais les
rapprochements des uns et des autres
même à l'extérieur sont encore limités
et donc un travail de pédagogie sera
fait par les parts laissant à l'ordre ce
sera la concentration du travail des
forces de l'ordre
celui qui n est toujours contre les
fêtes
autant destine par ailleurs et donc
effectivement nous pourrons lorsqu'on a
amené ses enfants pendant le cette
période très particulière de non
scolarisation puisqu'il y avait les
vacances avant c'est accepter de les
faire revenir sans quille et d'amandes
bien sûr il faudra logiciellement les
forces de l'anp s'ils font des contrôles
dans les gares dans les péages ou dans
tout autre lieu de transport enfin bien
merci à toutes et à tous
on n'a pas trop même
no spam